it is March 22nd 2023 and you're
watching the code report we're living
through an AI revolution in just the
last few days Stanford released alpaca
Ai and llm that can be trained for 600
and then subsequently took it down for
hallucinating too much being in Adobe
both announced their own AI image
generators Microsoft Office introduced
copilot but the biggest news is Bard is
now available as a public beta Google's
answer to gpt4 which is already being
put to use in its arch nemesis being
based on some data I just made up my
usage of Google Search has declined 63.9
percent since gpt4 came out last week
that's a terrifying statistic for Google
who makes most of its money from Google
search ads the good news for Google
though is that they have more data about
search than anybody else they have
virtually unlimited computing power on
their own custom Hardware called tpus
and a team of geniuses working on top
secret projects like quantum computers
they even declared Quantum Supremacy so
I have extremely high expectations for
Bard I compared it to gpt4 using four
different experiments and the results
are absolutely shocking but at first
what's with the name Bard apparently
it's supposed to mean Celtic storyteller
[Music]
I would name it something like
neurodominus 9000 or encephalon prime it
should strike fear in the hearts of the
microsofties the first thing I want to
find out is if this thing could write
code so I prompted it to build me a
basic to do app with JavaScript here we
have Bard on the left side and gpt4 on
the right side and amazingly Bard gets
the entire job done in just a few
seconds it takes gpt4 at least five
times longer to complete the same
problem that's pretty impressive but
going fast isn't very useful if you're
dumb let's find out if this code
actually works I ran the code in the
browser and opened the console and
immediately got an error basically it's
trying to add an event listener to an
element that doesn't exist I know what
the issue is but I want to see if Bard
can fix it I tell Bard it's not working
and paste the error message into the
prompt and it does come up with a
solution using a conditional statement
that would actually fix the error but it
doesn't make the application work
because that element still doesn't exist
I try to nudge it in the right direction
but then it hallucinates and tells me to
add an event listener to an input which
wouldn't work I keep trying to nudge it
but then it fails catastrophically
foreign
now if we look at the gpt4 response
you'll first notice how it's much more
well documented in addition when I try
to run the actual code I get a perfect
working to do app with no errors I ran
this experiment multiple times on
different demos and got similar results
so round one goes to gpt4 in round two
we'll see how creative it is when it
comes to idea generation I've always
wanted to write a romance novel so I
prompted it for some ideas The Bard
response was pretty simple and cliche
like the wrong man a man and woman meet
and fall in love blah blah blah it's
written at about an 8th grade level gpt4
has a lot more creative depth like
Stardust Melodies when a small town
musician Ella plans a gig at a
prestigious jazz club in New Orleans she
never expected to meet Alex a world
famous saxophonist struggling with his
own demons they Journey Through the
vibrant history of jazz to create a love
song that will last forever now that's a
[__] romance novel so gpt4 can come
up with better ideas but who can write
better poetry the next prompt is to
write a poem about programming and the
style of Dr Seuss in this example Bard
gets the job done with lines like I do
not like this coding prob I do not like
like it bought the job that's pretty
good and one thing that stands out here
is that it also provides a source for
this work which links back to some guy's
blog post which provides a little more
transparency into how it generated this
work bonus points to Bard for doing that
but now let's read gpt's four poem he'd
build them with care with love most of
all from the binary bird to the album
Rhythm as you can see they both sound
like Dr Seuss but there's just something
special about GPT each stanza just drips
off the tongue like honey and that
brings us to round four spitting facts
where I prompted them to explain how
brain waves work Bard is way faster at
outputting information which is very
useful for problems like this I'm in the
process of turning myself into a cyborg
for my next video so make sure you're
subscribed and I can tell you that both
of their responses are accurate I would
say gpt4 is slightly better but I'm
going to give this round a Bard because
I'm kind of starting to feel bad for it
Bart is also getting flamed on social
media right now and some people are
doing the unthinkable switching from
Google to Bing and Bard itself is
already paranoid that Google is going to
kill it off in the next one to two years
I never thought I would feel sorry for
an artificial intelligence but 2023 has
been a crazy decade this has been the
code report thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one